so Punk where's Queen Elsa you were the
last ice block she made so now it's time
to talk playing it cool huh well we have
ways of sweat ah now you're feeling the
heat so I ask you again where is Elsa
what do you say ah nothing turns out
water doesn't have a memory or a voice
or honestly anything that helps us solve
this case it is literally just water
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where it's January and that means it's
time to YouTube and chill since it's too
warm in Southern California to build a
snowman whether I wanna or not have to
find other ways to celebrate this time
of year so I'm cranking out a sequel of
my own unfrozen to just a silly but
somehow less of a cash grab the Disney's
version yes I am ready to break the ice
to talk about the most anticipated
animated sequel of all time with most
blatantly merchandize Abul costume
changes in Disney history in case you're
wondering yes there will be spoilers so
if you don't want to hear the ending
couldn't want to put this video on ice
and go watch the movie already or in
other words go get it over with now
despite the opening of this video I'm
not actually gonna talk about the big
theme of this movie which is water
having memory that's actually a theory
for another day nope
instead today I'm actually turning back
to frozen one to address the famous
adage from Elsa I don't know if you've
heard this one guys but the cold never
bothered also anyway apparently that's
their reasoning for her walking around
on mountaintops and silk-organza gowns
that are easy to mass produce for the
children of the world in one of our most
famous lines from the most famous song
the movie Elsa lets us all know that
part of her power said is that she's
impervious to how cold her ice castle is
not only that but she walks around in
the snow and has a gown with a very
chilly looking neckline but it doesn't
seem to matter because none of it can
affect her seems like a very clearly
defined power set I can respect that and
then he fast forward frozen to where
they throw all of it out the window
in frozen - we have this massive
climactic moment near the end of the
movie where we see Elsa freeze solid
what we just went over how Elsa can't be
hurt from the cold
oh she's literally swimming in the
Arctic Ocean and walking around in this
permafrost forest for days in a jacket
that's perfect for your next trip to
Walt Disney Land by the way and when we
see her defeated it's by freezing her to
death not only is it a blatant ripoff of
the climax of the last movie
ah no froze to death but just doesn't
make sense with Tulsa's power sir
the cold doesn't bother her so you know
what the question is a theorist watching
this movie have today well there are
just so many questions but the question
I want to ask today is this how cold
does it have to be to bother Elsa
clearly she's not immune to freezing so
what temperature does she freeze at what
is actually going on in the scene where
is the temperature that we get ourselves
a nice Elsa cold now in case you didn't
feed the Beast of the Disney sequel
machine or your memory of this movie is
foggy or you just checked out after the
words North old run at to Holland we
repeated like 47 times in this movie for
four-year-olds also winds up in this
chilly little predicament after
embarking on a quest at the behest of
well almost nothing some spirits were
whispering to her or something and
almost killing her entire kingdom but
they're not the same spirits we're
trapped in the misty wood it's super
confusing really inconsistent and not
that well written okay I just I got to
get that off my chest
anyway she journeys around the north to
claim her place as the ultimate ice
queen she abandons her sister who
clearly has PTSD from the last movie and
is angry about being left alone on this
journey which is a plotline that never
gets resolved fantastic she rides a
horse mermaid hybrid up to the north
country and forgets about Kristoff along
with the rest of the cast and crew of
this movie who is left alone to sing an
80s inspired power ballad the real
theory here is whether Disney knew how
badly put together this movie was but I
really don't need to get myself started
on that long story short what you need
to know for this theory is by the end of
the movie Elsa finds herself in the
north country in a dark mysterious ice
cave of self-discovery she falls a long
distance in two at bats head she freezes
eventually she gets thawed by the power
of who even cares anymore let's pretend
for the sake of this theory that they
were trying to make a movie with logical
cohesion and address how the heck a
literal Ice Queen could possibly freeze
to death is there an actual scientific
explanation here or was someone just
banking on a little too much Disney
magic if we're trying to figure out how
chilling it needs to be for Elsa to
freeze we need to get some perspective
on temperatures that were dealing with
throughout these movies we know that
Elsa has no problem surviving the cold
in the movies two primary settings
arendelle and the northern forests as
well as most of the other time that she
spends in the northern sea in Holland
how cold are these places and how much
colder is it when Elsa actually winds up
freezing
arendelle as you might already know is
between Erin doll and Bergen Norway Erin
doll for its namesake and Bergen for its
architecture and scenery we discussed
this in our previous little frozen
theory about the fact that Anna and Elsa
shouldn't be biological sisters which in
case you're interested you can catch up
on here if you missed it since that
theory Disney's released more
information about arendelle including a
map shown in frozen fever which we can
then cross-reference with the geography
of Norway since the only real feature
here is the forked rivers a search for
similar geographic areas in Norway and
found Alisoun an area that lined up
almost perfectly with a little map
manipulation the historic highs and lows
for all assumed in the fall which is
when the movie begins is seven point
seven to twelve point two degrees
Celsius or 46 to 54 degrees Fahrenheit
which gives us our parallels to
arendelle interestingly Allah soon
doesn't get very cold even in the winter
the highs and lows tend to hover just
above freezing
meaning that Elsa's winter wonderland
and frozen one would have been much
colder than the geographic norm
additionally we know North old roof the
Enchanted Forest is within a day or two
wagon ride from arendelle so we're
likely looking at the same temperature
averages there as well with maybe a
degree or two of difference none of the
people living there seem to be Keeling
over from frostbite so Elsa can just
survive there like everyone else so with
those two out of the way we can actually
focus on the more northern locations to
the movie the North Sea and Otto Holland
as Elsa journeys north again after
abandoning her sister in the middle of
nowhere we reach a point where according
to the frozen fever map she runs into
the Norse we which is Danish for North
Sea now the closest body of water north
of Norway on a real world map is the
Norwegian Sea interestingly the name of
the Norwegian Sea roughly translates to
sea of the north so it's a fair stand-in
a bit of research will tell you that the
Norwegian Sea especially the area is
close to the coastline that we're
dealing with all max out at about 5.9
degrees Celsius or forty point eight
degrees Fahrenheit which is not exactly
prime surfing temperature yearly
minimums of 1.3 degrees Celsius or 36
point two degrees Fahrenheit are
reported some waters that are just
barely above freezing making this some
seriously cold water and easily enough
to kill a normal person in a matter of
minutes
interestingly Xhosas ability to survive
in the cold water is perhaps more
impressive than our ability to survive
in icy castles on dry land
when you look at the thermodynamics of a
human and water falling into water as
warm as 68 degrees Fahrenheit or 20
degrees Celsius can trigger what's known
as a cold shock response which is the
same response you get if your shower
suddenly runs cold you gasp from
surprise as a reflexive part of the
response but if you're in a freezing
ocean the gas forces water down into
your lungs your limbs are suddenly
stunned from the shock of the cold and
you drown
almost immediately that's not scary
enough or you managed to avoid the cold
shock response you're still not in for a
good time even if you're in control of
your body to begin with you lose control
of your limbs in about ten minutes at
water fifty degrees or lower in
hypothermia your internal body
temperature dropping below 95 degrees
sets in in under an hour even in the
best possible conditions so for Elsa to
survive even minutes in the North Sea
waters she would have had to have been
wearing the equivalent of several
emergent water survival seats these big
old rubbery looking things this means
that in water where other people are
literally paralyzed and where body
temperatures would drop below
survivability in a matter of minutes
Elsa's maintaining a normal internal
body temperature and ice surfing with
the best of them it is unbelievable but
it doesn't freeze her that said one
final location to consider Holland is
the glacier of Highland that Elsa rides
to and what seems like a few minutes
from North old well initially I wanted
to say that this was intended to be
Iceland since the crew from frozen -
visited Iceland for Geographic
inspiration a movie it's just too far
north
honestly the closest coast of Iceland is
about 900 miles from Hollis food or any
part of the Norwegian coast which would
take a horse even a magic water horse
like 40 hours of straight running at top
speed with no rest to make our movie
travel more realistic I chose the small
island of can't pronounce those letters
just off the north coast of Norway
there's also possibilities like bear
island up here but you know they all
function basically about the same so
just loop them all in as potential
alcohol and standings interestingly all
these types of islands tend to have
sub-zero temperatures at least nine
months out of the year meaning that when
Elsa likely lands in Holland the
temperature is gonna cause water to
freeze directly onto her skin
immediately on top of that she's facing
ocean winds which will give her a
windchill effect making it feel even
colder for her starting at negative five
degrees Celsius the average temperature
for unpronounce
Norwegian Island in November we can
calculate wind chills for 10 to 30 miles
per hour or 16 to 48 km/h at these winds
Elsa's feel like temperature is gonna be
about negative 10 degrees Celsius
negative 15 degrees Celsius or 12
degrees Fahrenheit to 5 degrees
Fahrenheit even then there's not even a
shiver so we know even at temperatures
significantly below freezing it is still
not cold enough to bother her so geez
how cold does it need to be for me to
seem like a research dead-end since we
can't even guess about the temperature
in the magic cave she's in how far she's
falling things like that heck inside the
cave it probably should be warmer
because she's not subjected to being wet
in the wind that said who's one thing
that we can still speculate about Elsa
herself what if instead of looking at
the air around her the water that she's
impossibly swimming through all of that
stuff what if we stopped comparing her
to the way that humans freeze and stop
assuming that she's human at all instead
of assuming that her body functions like
a normal person's body it might make
more sense to assume that it functions
like the element that she's associated
with ice let's take a look at the moment
that Elsa freezes again we see her jump
into the ice chasm to follow her past
she falls for a couple of seconds and we
see her make a quick landing on her
hands and fingertips like this a moment
later she hears the truth about what
terrible imperialists her people were we
see her start to freeze again at her
fingertips and toes where she landed
interestingly it may be the only
scientifically accurate part of this
movie Elsa is freezing like ice to
better explain what I mean here and
what's actually happening to Elsa and
how her body functions I'm gonna need to
flip it to live action hey film
theorists matpat here might not look
like it because they have less hair up
here more hair down here but don't worry
that's what happens when you do a
charity livestream and put your hair on
the line I'll be back to my old self in
like t-minus three months who knows
anyway let's do some real world science
shall we back in high school because you
know this is not child-directed content
only 13 and up here on this channel you
may have done yourself a little
experiment in the realm of super cooling
now there are lots of YouTube videos out
there on this but I didn't feel like
trying to license those because they're
expensive and
science myself is really fun and cool so
anyway supercooling is just one of those
really nerdy things that's fascinating
to talk about and even more fascinating
to watch in person and frankly I just
kind of want to try it here since I have
the ability and people to film me doing
this sort of stuff so why not take
advantage of that this is also one of
those rare things on YouTube that you
can actually do yourself it might take a
couple of times to get it right but the
idea is to cool a bottle of water I'm
gonna go get the bottle of water I'm
gonna take off my microphone and then
get the bottle chris is gonna go get the
bottle of water thank you Chris
hopefully super chilled ready to be
crystallized now the things they got a
note here are the water first and
foremost needs to be clean and it needs
to be left very still no this is because
in a freezer water will actually cool
below freezing temperatures after a
couple hours but still have a magic area
where it stays in a liquid state because
it doesn't have what's called a seed
crystal just a couple of crystal
structures in the water that ice can
form onto now there's a lot of
complicated math that goes behind seed
crystals but for our purposes we're
gonna think about Elsa in frozen to as
our little bottle of water here probably
could have cut out a face and stuck it
on here right
little adele dazeem action figure here
she looks human right but in the movie
because she represents the ice element
at a molecular level
her body is actually behaving more like
freezing water than it does a person now
when Elsa falls down in that ice cave
and hits the bottom we suddenly see her
whole body crystallize into an Elsa
popsicle kind of like we should see with
this experiment ready Dan ready Chris
it's gonna land right here ready three
two one
and you see see it it's that's going
it's going what you're seeing here are
water molecules so that's suddenly
colliding into each other a little seed
crystal at the top and all the water
molecules hitting into it and glomming
on crystallizing into that structure
proceeding all the way down into the
bottle until now we have mostly ice with
a little bit of water left over how much
not a whole lot
okay a little bit more than I expected
but you can see that as soon as there
was a big impact on that bottle
disturbing the super chilled water
inside of it the entire thing
crystallized from the top down to the
bottom now this happened because when
the bottle dropped onto the table it
sent a shock wave through the liquid
literally forcing water molecules to
bump into each other through randomness
that extra movement eventually results
in water molecules forming something
close to the crystal structure of ice
once that happens the water suddenly has
the seed crystals that it needs and now
more water molecules quickly bump into
that seed crystal and align themselves
into the proper structure locking in and
freezing almost instantly in Elsa's case
in frozen 2 we see the crystallization
or nucleation process as it's cold start
from her extremities right her feet and
her fingertips where she landed on the
ground but if we were really being
scientifically accurate would actually
start from the top of her head because
that is the end of the shock wave that
she experienced from falling that said
this experiment still provides the best
explanation that we have about how an
ice queen could freeze to death she's
not a human who controls ice at a
molecular level she actually is ice
herself in a very roundabout way this
explanation also helps us understand why
Elsa's impervious to cold climates cold
air heck even brutal wind chills at a
molecular level elsa is effectively
colder than all of those things she is
supercooled meaning that they're not
cooling her she is the one that's
cooling them it's science
it's frozen
it is super cool literally and
figuratively
fascinatingly even understanding that
else's body functions like a supercooled
liquid it still doesn't give us a true
sense of our molecular temperature
according to a 2018 study at the
University of Frankfurt in Germany
supercooled water can reach temperatures
of negative 42 point 5 5 degrees Celsius
or negative 44 degrees Fahrenheit
meaning that Elsa has the potential to
achieve a massive range of temperatures
that would allow her to not only survive
the harshest conditions on earth but
even survive in some places on freezing
planets like Mars and all of this
actually makes sense in the context of
the movie for as convoluted as its lore
is just like the earth Giants are made
of rock the wind spirit has literally
just wind and the waterhorses water just
ignore that dumb little cute fyrelizard
Elsa is made up of the element that she
controls if she truly is the fifth
elemental creature which honestly she
shouldn't be because ice isn't in
element that's different from water
horse over there but still if ice truly
is a different element in this world her
being supercooled and only freezing from
a landing that strikes hard makes
perfect sense so in an ironic twist Elsa
truly is impervious to cold as long as
she doesn't get smacked too hard by
anything for future reference to all the
villains in the inevitable frozen 3 skip
all the swords or guns or flamethrowers
or whatever just give Elsa good ol womp
with a frying pan tangled style organ -
a particularly aggressive pillow fight
and frankly she is done for don't tell
anyone I tipped you off though because
if you're a regular viewer of this
channel you'll know that Mickey Mouse
and I already have ourselves a chilly
relationship but hey that's just a
theory
this island that I cannot pronounce nor
can I find any online pronunciation
guide because it's just really hard to
find pronunciations for very small areas
can I just say first sorry cut cut the
video oh you travel logs on YouTube
right now why do you not talk in then
there are so many Norwegian travel logs
that I've clicked on as I research this
video hoping that someone will teach me
how to pronounce the names of these
places and all of them are just clips
set to music with moderate amounts of
text on top it's not helping me please
teach me how to pronounce these places
not even Wikipedia has a pronunciation
guide for this well
Saur fuglie Ola I mean look at these
letters what am I supposed to do with
this it's a zero it's an O that's been
crossed out it's like no no thank you
oh this is a no pronunciation old and
geez would you even puts a G there sore
folk sore fug Lowa sore fou Glo ah can
someone watching this video in Norway
can you please upload videos of you
pronouncing sore fug Lua and then link
them to me on Twitter matpat GT or in
the game theorist subreddit and I will
try to make a greatest hits compilation
of all of them and we'll do a community
tab post or something of it that'd be
great
please teach me how to pronounce sore
fugly uh cut